Bank of America
JPMorgan Chase Citigroup it
Wells Fargo double-a together made more
than four billion dollars in pre-tax
income from their credit card business
between July and September did you hear
that those four banks from July to
September made four billion dollars off
of your stupidity America did you hear
it the article says the amount of debt
owed by American consumers which receded
in the wake of the financial crisis is
again on the rise outstanding credit
card debt the total balances that
customers roll from month to month hit a
record one trillion dollars this year
according to the Federal Reserve the
number of Americans with at least one
credit card has reached 171 million the
highest level in more than a decade
according to TransUnion and credit
reporting company that is occurring in
an opportune moment for the banking
industry which is suddenly struggling to
earn as much money from traditional
profit engines making it I'm so glad
you're helping them out Oh in the years
since the financial crisis the largest
United States financial institutions
churned out profits largely thanks to a
booming business and trading and
structuring bonds and other securities
now though those businesses are flagging
in part because financial markets have
been eerily calm so banks are turning to
more lending to consumers especially
through credit cards to pick up some of
the slack banks earn more money from
credit cards our banks earned money from
credit cards in two ways they take a
small cut of each charge card
transaction as a fee which they also do
with debit cards by the way and they
typically charge annual interest rates
of 15% or more on balances that
customers don't pay off at the end of
the line that business model is
increasingly lucrative well no duh many
consumers their wages stagnant
and their costs rising are growing
reliant on credit cards Oh bullcrap
consumers are buying crap they can't
afford with money they don't have to
impress people they don't really like
and they're putting it on stupid plastic
shovel debt shoveled down their throats
by Bank of America JPMorgan Chase
Citigroup and Wells Fargo that's what's
really happening don't blame the poor
low consumer their wages are stagnant
the portal consumer has to go into debt
oh you whiners it's not anything to do
with the portal consumer it's just
stupidity it's just stupid across the
industry profits rose in the latest
quarter spending on plastic is part of
the broader debt bonanza in May total
household debt levels hit a post
recession peak of twelve point seven
trillion dollars but what's good for
banks and their shareholders isn't
necessarily good for bank customers well
duh
listen this crap these cards are a
social safety net says Charles Djou
quinta a bankruptcy lawyer in Manhattan
because bankruptcy lawyers in Manhattan
they know about social safety nets
because they live in Manhattan give me a
break seriously Charles
he said he's seen thousands of clients
made insolvent by a single unexpected
cost no Charles they were made insolvent
the fact they never saved any money
they'll always spend everything they
made and then when they had a single
unexpected cost they weren't ready
that's why they were insolvent Charles
for borrowers with shaky credit interest
rates can be near 36 percent some
borrowers end up owing more in interest
than they originally spent on their
cards shocking really the cost of
borrowing is creeping upward the average
interest rate on a new credit card
currently hovers sixteen point one five
percent the highest level and at least a
decade
banks this is especially welcome because
relatively few borrowers appear to be at
risk of default and that means the banks
are pocketing big fees and interest
payments with minimal costs so let's get
this straight okay default rates are
lower than they have been the cost of
capital what banks pay for money the Fed
Funds rate is almost zero
they're almost paying nothing for their
money and then they're loaning it back
out to you at an average of sixteen
point one six but if you have a little
bit of Darkness on your credit it could
be up there around thirty six percent
for you cuz you're special yes you are
we want to take good care of you yes
seriously when are you gonna wake up a
trillion dollars in plastic what are you
gonna wake up when are you gonna look at
him and say you know what the credit
card is the cigarette of the financial
world hey I was a kid everybody smoked
my parents smoked like chimneys man when
I was a kid we had nicotine running down
the walls and the house everybody smoked
everybody smoked on TV everybody smoked
cigarettes now if you smoke cigarettes
you're like low class or something right
you know I remember you can smoke on
airplanes and I remember you can smoke
in restaurants and then there was a no
smoking section in an airplane now that
makes a lot of sense right it's a tube
like the smoke is gonna stay in one end
of the tube give me a break here or this
might non-smoking section and the
restaurant you remember that now
everybody's huddled outside the door
because you can't eat smoke in the
building they're all huddled outside
smoking cigarettes you know you know
I'll stand around freezing to death you
ever say we're standing in the rain cuz
I got such a nicotine habit they're
stuck in the rain smoking it's like we
pity people the smoke now I mean you
just didn't get the memo this stuff
kills you and your breath stinks too I
mean you didn't get the memo nobody told
you this is a
low class behavior and it kills your
butt I mean if you're not did since I
was a kid it went from being cool to
being not cool to smoke cigarettes
because people realize it kills you and
it stings and then quit I'm not mad at
you personally if you smoke I'm just
talking about Society has made a swing
in the way they view smokers would you
agree with that even if you're a smoker
you would have to right you'd have to
nod your head and say yes why why his
society shifted on smoking because it
kills you and it stinks the credit card
is the cigarette of the financial world
it was cool man I mean you're in college
and they gave you a credit card will
give you a free hat will give you a
t-shirt will give you a pizza man and so
begins the addiction it was cool to get
credit I mean I got a gold card look at
me man I'm gold baby I'm solid gold you
remember and now we all kind of grin and
look at this absurdity of that don't we
just look at that and go that's stupid
that's just dumb now the credit card
will kill you not physically but
financially it'll kill you you just
don't meet rich people the credit card
that hello well I wouldn't be happier if
I was rich people no dummy you'd be rich
people if you didn't have credit card
that you got it backwards I mean you
just don't get rich paying people 16%
but by god they're getting rich have you
looked at the size of their buildings
and the quality of their furniture it
beats your double-wide so you gonna stop
and think folks when people like Wells
Fargo own the world because you gave
them the deed it's your fault get that
stupid plastic out it's time for plastic
surgery baby it's time for A+ ectomy get
you a debit card and get out the credit
card business it's the cigarette of the
financial world it'll kill you and it
stinks and it's no longer cool used to
be cool it's not cool anymore we
declared that about a decade ago and
people are catching on this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]